make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so in a previous video I had talked
about black Tom Cassidy right now I was
like what black Tom Cassidy sucks and
for a long time he did write he could
use wood as a means to basically shoot
but shoot like plant energy essentially
like concussive blasts and he blasts
things like that he was never really
interesting uh he is now dude x-force is
legit dude he's amazing and x-force but
here's the cool thing about this right
so getting into this x-force initially
picks up with this kind of dark council
essentially it's kind of gathering of
various individuals from around the
world now here's a funny thing they're
all wearing masks right so we don't know
who all these guys are it's kind of cool
because it almost feels like a throwback
to to Scott Snyder's run on Batman and
the court of owls but in order for each
of them to be able to be on the council
or to prove who they are there's a blood
test and the blood test will basically
determine if they're mutants or if
they're not means now this is an easy
thing to overlook is a small thing to
kind of look at and say okay cool
whatever kind of the big thing to draw
out of this is that this is yet another
example of how after the formation of
cacoa
there are a lot of organizations
governments different groups out there
that are working against mutant kind and
it's not as simple it's just like the
Marauders I guess not earlier than the
Marauders anymore because that's a
wholly different team but the forces of
mr. sinister the purifiers or like the
right or the the Friends of humanity
it's not like it's just them instead
like it's whole governments working
against the entirety of the mutant
population whether this because they
refuse to let meetin's go from the
country or because they're intentionally
trying to sabotage Cocoa's ability to
like create plants and things like that
they can heal people whatever the case
is the character of Domino was sent in
because Herman powers basically luck by
she bins luck to her favor she was sent
in as it means to infiltrate this
council and then in turn once the blood
test was done or at least you know what
she tried to avoid it immediately her
cover was blown and all these guys went
after her right now she was able to take
at least a lot of these guys out or at
least had seemed to be the case until
she's ultimately captured in at that
point she falls off the grid right so we
don't really know what's going on with
it instead what we do here is we pick up
with Wolverine and we pick up with Beast
now beast in this story here's the thing
this is drawn beautifully right like the
art in this is insanely gorgeous om so
beast looks amazing in this story but
the cool thing about this is that this
really feels like classic Wolverine
right like Wolverine from like the 1980s
is what this feels like insofar as when
he's talking to beasts there's this
predator that kind of comes out of
nowhere right and basically like goes to
try to attack these and and ultimately
the predator is essentially scared off
by beast animal rant and the initial
response is of beasts is like this
doesn't make any sense because krakoa is
supposed to be an island design to
basically be a safe haven for mutant con
but the responsible brain is in every
ecosystem there's always predators right
there's this an unavoidable think they
will evolve over time it's just the way
things work he says the problem with
beasts is that beasts felt safe and this
is one of the best moments of Wolverine
he says when you feel safe that's when
you're soft and this is a cool thing to
see when it comes to Wolverine this this
is something that I've really noticed
ever since the events of schism when it
comes to Wolverine I wouldn't really say
he was softer so much as he became more
human and well that's not the worst
thing ever the best stories an involved
Wolverine or when he tapped into his
animal side the part of him that just
kind of like you know you can't trust
anything or anyone
you always have to basically be on high
alert yes it's like a super stressful
way to live but it's cool because it's
kind of a calling card a Wolverines
character and it's interesting to see
things that way now the other part of
this is switching is switching over to
black todd Cassidy so the funny thing
about black Tom Cassidy is that in his
original stories he could shoot this
kind of you know concussive blast more
or less by using wood as a means to
channel his power and Generation X
number 25 back in 97 model change that
right they basically gave him control
over a plant-based matter the problem
with this is that between the stories
were written from Generation Next number
25 really up until about now
model never really took full advantage
of that what this does is it basically
it gives us that and it makes the most
sense right because wall krakoa is a
living island insofar as it does have
sentience you're talking about a guy who
can control plant life that in turn is
living on a living Island right so as
long as for koa let's Tamas Kassai and
let's black Tom Cassidy do his thing he
can essentially control the plant life
of the planet and this is important
because what it means is he can
communicate with krakoa now it's not as
is easily understood as like cypher
anger color right like cypher actually
understands the language croco speech so
it's like it's like if you were talking
to somebody who speak who spoke French
and now you can speak French then you
understand them perfectly with black Tom
Cassidy it's more of trying to get a
feel for what kocoum eats right like
gestures and different things like that
right so if you only spoke English and
another person only spoke French and
they're making gestures towards an
object like I'm talking about that
object eventually you would understand
it over time that's kind of what's going
on with black Tom Cassidy at the moment
but he's a guy
who can essentially control and
manipulate an entire island and the
funny thing about this is he's basically
hit up by Jean Grey now the reason why
this matters is because of the fact that
one Jean Grey is kind of early alert
system right and so far she has
telepathy so on and so forth and that's
cool but the thing to understand about
cacoa is that while krakoa is a living
Island kirko it has feelers that extend
further beyond really like kind of in
the surrounding areas and so what this
means is that if there's something going
on around them the only kokoa can pick
up say for example like a submarine is
headed their way that croco could pick
it up Agricola could in turn alert black
Tom Cassidy or alert Seifer but because
black Tom Cassidy is kind of connected
to the island he would pick it up at
around the same time which is exactly
what happens here that when jean grey
says hey look there's some incoming by
tom caches responses I know like we're
going to check it out and see what's
going on now initially the mutant
population begins to panic right lay the
people who are aware that something's
coming begin to freak out and rightfully
so because remember one of the things
that Hickman established in the house
and powers of X is that the only way to
get to or from Tekoa is to pass through
any one of the portals that are
available that are created by the plants
that are offered by krakoa the only
exception to this is the Marauders of
Kitty project and when people don't
initially know it's her they started to
freak out like oh my god somebody's on
their way over here now the reality is
you would expect that there wouldn't
really be anybody foolish enough to
attack krakoa head-on right given the
sheer number of mutants that are there
but it's kind of a cool thing here
because it's like okay this is awesome
but then Jean Grey chimes in and says
there's something else aboard that boat
something filled with pain and what we
end up getting here is this realization
that on this boat is none other than
Colossus and this is awesome because
what's been going on here since the the
failed wedding more or less of Colossus
a Huey probably where they didn't
actually get married what you ended up
getting was Colossus kind of falling off
the grid or at least that seeming to be
the case what he's been doing is
operating inside of Russia and
essentially helping to smuggle mutants
out and this is a really really cool
thing and the reason why is because what
we don't really see a whole lot of that
we only get small little snippets of
stuff here and there if it's perfectly
in line with Colossus right because he's
not really a pacifist he's not only a
guy who's like I don't really want to
fight he's more like a gentle giant but
he's one of those guys were like when it
hits the fan you want him on your side
right his osmium metal skin mixing him
makes him almost impervious to a variety
of different things right like most
forms of weapons out there he can't hurt
it extreme temperatures can either an
extreme hot or extreme cold of course
magneto manipulating metal different
things like that can but also any
weapon they can basically scramble or at
least manipulates metal itself like anti
D aunty metal vibranium or like you know
anti power weapons those things can kind
of scramble as power stillman to
disarray and insulin and so forth but
it's cool to see the Colossus is
basically making his return here the
problem with this is that Colossus
experience going through and basically
working in this kind of underground
railroad so to speak within Russia by
basically helping to smuggle mutants to
freedom from their from their captivity
his is taken like a psychological and a
physical toll on Colossus right because
it's one thing to get out there and to
say okay we're gonna fight these very
exposed it's another to see the kind of
horrific and inhumane experiments that
they were conducting on mutants in a
means as it means to like control their
powers and possibly synthesize them
different things like that and it can
screw somebody up and so as a result of
that Colossus is in a pretty rough
position he's in a pretty bad place now
what you also end up having here this is
where this is where the plot really kind
of begins to come into play what you
have going on here if you basically have
a couple of people who basically get on
board a plane this plane heading for
whatever today a destination happens to
be but there's just two people who were
there they both look at each other and
they both recognize each other
indicating something is afoot who these
people are I will talk about here in a
second but what this also does is it
shows Charles Xavier heading towards
you're heading to sokovia which is a
place that on the the front service
seems to be in support of mutants but
one of the things that's being hit on
here is that for a lot of countries out
there the public eye is they support
Nakoa the reality of the country is
they're starkly against them and so this
seems to be one of those instances a lot
of this really kind of seems to be
because of the fact that when Xavier is
given a drink there appears to be
something in it now we don't really know
what that is we're not really 100% sure
what that is but Jimmy back to this
these two people that got onboard this
plane suddenly like everything starts to
kind of go nuts right like the plane
really seems like it's it's hitting you
know extreme turbulence or they're
losing losing altitude
but whatever the circumstance of course
the oxygen masks come down and because
oxygen masks on planes are designed to
subdue passengers as opposed to just
allow you to breathe that of course it
knocks all the passengers out right and
so as a result of that this is when this
guy basically kind of jumps up we end up
finding out the woman who was there has
essentially seized control of the
cockpit and not only that it's not just
those two it's two others and so they
basically formed this entire team now
here's why I think this matters and
here's why I think this is so cool it's
possible they could be any number of
people out there any number of
historically anti-mutant groups writing
the Friends of humanity who were
for conservatives the right which were
like these ultra conservative
nationalist Pro humanity groups that
existed out there but I think and I
think it'd be really really awesome if
this turned out to be the purifiers I
think it would be amazing if like
William Stryker is back again like
William Stryker is here again and he's
basically implementing this and the
reason why that works is because
remember William Stryker despite the
fact that he is more or less disgraced
still has a lot of resources at his
disposal and a lot of contacts that he
can tap into and so if that's true and
if it is William Stryker and if it is
the purifiers this works awesome because
where you end up having like like Xavier
who's basically meeting with black Tom
Cassidy and talking to him you have sage
who's kind of monitoring the whole thing
those guys who were unfamiliar with sage
she's a mutant whose mind works like a
computer right so she never forgets
information and it categorizes and
stores things perfectly so she can
basically achieve perfect recollection
right let perfect memory recall it's
really cool how her powers work she
doesn't really have any offensive powers
right no energy blasts no super-strength
or anything like that her mine is their
greatest weapon but it's why she's here
right because she's a huge asset for any
sort of mutant group that's basically
focusing on intelligence or needs an
intelligence side and so in the middle
of all this when when sage begins to
realize that it's not Domino when black
top a black Tom Cassidy picks up on the
same thing it's you gotta go like you
got to get out of here Xavier you got to
run for your life because River Xavier
is the heart and soul of this whole
thing right Xavier is the guy they have
to keep a lot now it's not just because
of the purpose he serves insofar as
being this kind of guy alongside Magneto
that basically helps her to kind of
control what's going on but it's also
because he's a kind of a moral
figurehead if they lose him it could
demoralize a lot of the mutants that are
out there they would immediately lose
faith in the idea of Kirk OA and they
would say well if they could get here
and kill Xavier then like how does this
bode for the rest was they can kill us
all so it's kind of a big thing there
but when these forces show up when these
four folks show up suddenly all hell
begins to break loose bullets are firing
all over the place ah black Tom Cassidy
Sims Xavier fleeing for his life doesn't
like gets a refuge hide underground and
do whatever he needs to do you have
Wolverine who basically flees and this
is when things get cool because why Tom
Cassidy is like you've come here to this
living Island right this thing is
composed of trees and plants and all
manner of things to oppose a mutant
population one of which who is me can
control plant life you've picked the
worst possible place to engage in any
any battle whatsoever and black
cassadee for the forces that oppose him
he tears them to pieces rips these guys
to pieces not only that beats jumps in
and beast actually just like guts a guy
and so it's cool to kind of see that
whole thing go down right because it's
basically like these folks have shown up
here and it's the first real attack on
piccola it's the first real attack on
this this this entire island this is
straight head-on physical altercation
and so for the most part a lot of these
mutants well I wouldn't say they're all
falling a lot of them are really being
taken out by these guys who were there
and so ultimately Jean Grey and beast
and and Wolverine end up tracking down
Xavier finally locating where he's at
only to get there just in time to see
him shot in the face to see Xavier
basically shot and killed and this is a
crazy situation right because you're
one-issue innocent like Xavier comes
back after the events of house of M
where he has the ability to walk and he
walks around for a long long time he
does a whole bunch of cool stuff
everything all runs into Avengers vs.
x-men win like Cyclops kills it right so
then Xavier comes back during the events
of the man named X storyline and now
he's dead again right like he's dead
after that here's the important thing to
understand here is that when when it
came to writing the extras and Jonathan
Hickman did an interview about this
wouldn't when it came to writing the
x-men one of the biggest problems he
thought the x-men had is at the entirety
of their mythos for the last however
long was exceedingly dark and full of
death if there were characters out there
half of them had lost their powers or
the other half were dead and you
couldn't do anything with him but what
Hickman did not want to do was use death
as a means to like oh my god a character
died you know it's some kind of like
story seller right like the idea of
death in comics is supposed to serve the
purpose of continuing this story moving
forward and giving us a reason to care
and so that's why he invoked the idea of
mutants constantly being resurrected and
so all this would mean is that if Xavier
really has been shot in the face which
he has then only have to do is resurrect
it but the cool thing about this is that
it's not designed for the purpose of
like we have to get you know revenge on
these guys whatever because they killed
Xavier because he's not dead
instead this allows the story to move
forward in a direction of they launched
an attack on us we have to go find out
who it was that did this and take them
out that's what it allows the story to
focus on it doesn't focus on the death
of Charles Xavier
if dying in the comics doesn't mean
anything that in turn is the one thing
you're not focusing on if you know the
characters are always going to come back
one you don't have to worry about the
idea of they're gone forever - it's not
a gimmick and three it allows you to
focus on what the writers actually doing
with the story instead of seeing the
dead
is this cheap desire to sell comics you
know some kind of parlor trick or
something like that so I kind of want to
throw that out there I thought it was a
cool little interview that hickman did
well that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain it make
sure you all hit the sub button to
become part of the rod core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]